air plants airhead education hello and
welcome to Friday re for all of yous
that don't for all of yous that don't
know so close for all of you that do not
know friary is a look back at my week in
vlog form and because we had an extra
video an extra video because we announce
the movie last week I didn't put up
Friday every last week so this is two
weeks compa lated together compilation
is a word they're not arguing it so so
here are some of the things that have
happened to me over the last two weeks
this happened a little Bray diary it is
Saturday and we are headed downtown
Louie we are going downtown daily and we
are going to shoot a sketch with Anna
Akana I'm very excited because she
doesn't half-ass a sketch here's a
spoiler I had to get fitted for a
bodysuit for this sketch so it's gonna
be fantastic and I'm really excited to
work with her she was on the podcast a
few weeks ago listen to the episode if
you have it and she's just funny and
smart what an excellent combo let's go
shoot some funny smart stuff with her
yeah
and then this happened
hi for diary it is Sunday night I'm
watching some releasing vlogs and I have
a lot of work to do so of course I
decided to paint this room
Green is always um bothered me because
it's a little too bright and the rest of
the house is really like neutral calm
colors so I'm painting at this light
blue which might end up being a primer
for another color but it's happening
it's like 11 p.m.
oh by the time this video goes up you'll
know so tomorrow morning Monday
maimry Hannah and I start rehearsals for
dirty 30 the new film that we are doing
which is super exciting and also very
nerve-wracking so I went for a jog and
now I'm painting a lot of other things I
should be doing but you know this is
very therapeutic lord knows I can use
all the therapy I could get
oh my God look at these two I'll charge
it to you do the bit I missed a bit
yeah it was a really horrible line who's
about expensable
that's what why you probably want to
waste your digital cameras very telling
script title written by name of first
writer based on if any yes this is how
rehearsal happens where I live now
because I can't move hey guys normal
days you look at the life of glamour
relieved I know it's really nice and
then this happened
what I got sar bums kids are patch kids
Oh sour punch little loser
I got a cookie that's your business card
and then I've got a pop one
Danko's in a good show and a good
attitude all the ingredients to enjoy a
film here's something yes good bring it
home to victory you are a metaphor for
my life
this is this is it you got it on the
rail oh hey still happy that you ripped
up an entire branch in the living room
do this then went to New York City for
streamcon thank you very much boys
apparently this
we're rolling streamcon today god bless
me oh my god he's purring you're cooler
than I'll ever be in my oh my gosh Doug
and beans need to clap don't mind this
just my parents getting out of the limo
oh yeah Perry so I found an experienced
cold I came back and then this happened
hello friary it is Wednesday I did not
feel much at the beginning of this week
because sometimes you need to take
mental health days that's what I
realized and it's okay I am leaving my
first fitting for dirty 30 will be very
exciting I've suitcases because I
brought all of my clothes to to
contribute since we this thing's low
budget guys just to keep that in mind
low budget big hearts can't lose
subscribers because you can't subscribe
to the movie yes you can xxx xxx movie
calm and I'm going home great update
gotta go and then this happened I'm
sweaty hello for a diary by now you know
that trivy the trivia app launched by
Chester C and rhett and Link is
available in the App Store if you like
trivia games and you like youtubers it's
a really awesome trivia app that is not
only just like a general trivia game but
there are I think over sixty expansion
packs geared towards trivia about a
specific youtuber that you can download
which is so exciting it's currently
Wednesday night right Wednesday
afternoon and tonight at midnight it
launches here's hoping that when this
video goes live it has done well you
guys are enjoying it but in celebration
of it launching I just went to Michael's
crafts and I bought so many things and I
bought Sephora makeup for myself but I
bought all of these crafts to try and
decorate the house like the game and
make
cake like try to make fancy exciting
cake I don't know why I wanted to do
that but I wanted to do that so we're
gonna do that in launch of trivia and
Chester see we so we're gonna let's
start decorating this is the before okay
and this is the after it is 9:20 p.m.
right now or some decoration hashtag
trivy sign that I made some gifts some
just general like color scheme Oh more
like general color scheme and this might
be the best part I made a cake well I
made a cake and it has a specific
message to the competitors of trivy jk
jk quiz up you're a great app so Chester
should be back in a second yay goosey so
excited oh yeah goose is wearing she's
wearing a shirt that is appropriate for
the occasion so um you'll probably see
it good morning friary it is Thursday
and Truby has launched Chinese mom yeah
and it seems like you guys really like
it and that's so exciting it hope so
yeah it's been a long work in progress
so it's so fun that you guys get to
share it and now with you if you haven't
already go to the App Store and download
trippy the trivia app and to celebrate
trippy being out we're gonna go get
burritos
breakfast burrito look at this yeah my
ribs autistic I had a joke and you
ruined it take to let you laugh lessors
of that I don't but cuz you didn't this
time in the middle of my turtle dojo
okay take to pretend you didn't see that
Friday look at this beautiful burrito
burrito monster she doesn't get it Oh
more secrets and now it is actually
Friday I woke up this morning and wanted
to make jewelry and look and you read
what it says I'm working on it
it's the first one it's a statement it's
a statement necklace get it I made it
there's a lot of things happening right
now on Monday we actually start
production for dirty thirty we start
shooting on Monday which is bonkers and
I'm nervous and excited I goose is
making every possible noise that happens
Monday
let's see Oh Hannah member and I
announced that we are going to Australia
this December with the no filter show so
there's a link in the description get
your tickets please we're only doing a
couple shows and we I've never been to
Australia it's a long trek to get there
so I don't think we're gonna be back
anytime soon and these shows are selling
out very quickly so please please please
get your tickets ASAP if you really want
to be there what else is there Trippi
launched yeh that's there go get that if
you like that um also I'm nominated for
a People's Choice Award for
you tuber cool you tuber ish kind of
thing among a bunch of really great
other youtubers that it gets
mirandasings Tyler Oakley jenna Marbles
Connor Franta I think but the link to
vote is down there because you people
choose the awards People's Choice Awards
if you want to vote for any of those
human beings myself included go down
there and vote because that's cool
oh look ah okay so my second book Grace
and style the art of pretending you have
it it's just about completely done and I
am so excited about it it comes out
February 2nd if you want to preorder it
now you can the link is down below and
I'm thinking every Friday and Friday re
I'm going to have a little book bonus
section some you know quick snippet to
talk to you guys about the book I also
want to do a couple live streams this
month where I get to talk to you guys in
real time about the book because it was
meant to be something really kind of
surface and silly and stupid and it has
all of those qualities but it ended up
being something really personal to and
really um that yeah it's that so I'm
really excited and nervous about it in a
good way I guess I won't start book
bonus this week but I want to start them
next week so leave me some questions you
might have about the book in the cop
Devil's trying to get out at me
leave me some questions in the comment
section that you might have about the
book that I can speak about next week
and then I'm just so excited about it
so go pre-order the book now if you like
things like that I think that's all of
the plugs that I have I need an
extension cord because I have used all
of your outlets I'm so sorry
uh yeah
I don't know I don't know what Starbucks
red cups are I thought pumpkin spice
latte is for the only thing that we
celebrated from Starbucks in the fall
I'm speaking the collective we like it's
some religion I don't know what red cups
are it's their holiday cups and it makes
coffee taste different question mark
sincere question girls all my social
media seem to care about red cups so
much that I made a joke how do we
combine birth control and red cups
because the care that women have for red
cups and the importance that birth
control has if we just combine them life
would be so much easier for ladies so
many of you guys so like go to sleep
grace are you drunk
sleep what okay huh I'd lay off the coke
right about now smiley face guys give me
half a chance
Darrin diesel says is red cups and birth
control the new Netflix and chill I hope
so